this is tom cruise matt lauer and
you know tom is a scientologist who does
not believe in medication yeah he does
not believe in taking
you know antidepressants he doesn't
believe in ritalin he doesn't believe in
any of that stuff i don't know where you
stand with this medication stuff he's
not for it and matt lauer saying what's
wrong if this helped that brook shields
what's wrong if this helps out says you
don't realize what this is doing this is
ruining their lives this is not helping
them do you realize how many different
countries this is illegal in do you
realize that britain is only legal in a
couple different countries it's not many
countries it's not a legal drug in other
places it's legal and he's explaining
this
and believe it or not afterwards they
pinned tom cruise to be
a
you know almost an [ __ ] like a
misogynist like of course what does it
matter with you insensitive you're not
passionate you're not somebody that
cares about another person years later
tom cruise looks like the hero but in
the heat of the moment he didn't come
out really good right so we're living in
an era where you're right a part of it
is it you're not feeling that you're
depressed take two of these see what
happens to you
it's the hero's arc and this is the
thing this is why what i'm saying when
people say you don't know what you don't
know how it feels to be depressed to say
yes i do the difference is how it's
analyzed i always argue this two ways as
well when depressed people come to me
because one of my most famous things
people attack me for
is their little quote is they say you
said depression isn't real what about
the man who kills themselves you don't
care about men's mental health we've
already discussed how i care more about
mental health and these people who
[ __ ] pretend they do this the first
thing say i didn't say depression isn't
real i said feeling depressed is real
but the idea that depression is going to
strike you in your mind and there's
nothing you can do about it i think that
is promoting helplessness amongst
depressed people and that's the reason
they kill themselves i don't think that
making people helpless in an unfortunate
situation is the great thing to do you
have to give people hope
and i explained that
when you believe in something you give
it power so i tried to say that when i
felt at my lowest and i achieved the
most i've ever achieved in my life the
reason i was capable of doing that is
because i didn't believe in the paradigm
of being a depressed person i just
believe that this is how i currently
feel and [ __ ] it i'm gonna do whatever
it takes to get my life to be better
and i gave a very simple example an
analogy i said if you take two people
one believes in ghosts and one doesn't
you put them both in haunted houses
and in the middle of the night there's a
bat
the person who believes in ghosts
is now terrified there's a ghost they're
calling an exorcist or panicking in the
room they're hiding the person who
doesn't believe in ghosts goes wind and
goes back to sleep
it's the same noise it's the same
scenario but it's the belief that's both
in their mind
that tariff and ruins their life it's
the belief in their mind that turns
against them and i've said this many
times
i don't even give a [ __ ] about right and
wrong you can tell me depression's you
can give me every scientific proof in
the world depression but
i refuse to believe in things that take
my power away from me
i only i'm only going to construct a
mental model that allows me to be as
powerful as possible if believing in the
idea of depression is going to take my
own power away then i won't believe in
it i don't want to believe in things
that make me weak if you want to reach
me i'm on minute minik is a new app it's
fantastic it allows me to interact
directly with people i get a lot of
messages on email a lot of dms and those
kind of things but the people who are
serious who want to have serious
conversations and grow from them whether
it's a business opportunity or personal
experience et cetera i'm on minute and i
can't wait to interact with the serious
individuals of the world
i believe in things that make me strong
and someone goes well you're wrong
listen
let's assume let's assume you're correct
and that makes me wrong let's say that
you're right and you're depressed why
would i want to adopt the thinking of a
man who is sad
why would i want to think like you
wouldn't it better to be wrong and be
happy and have a sports car and a yaw
and a private jet you want to talk about
right look at your life
why i don't talk about right and wrong
let's talk about success and results i
don't believe in things that take power
from me i never have so when people
email me and they start saying i'm
depressed and depressed depressed and
what's funny is this
i talk to them
and they desperately defend the idea of
depression i'm like my friend you just
told me you're too depressed to be
successful and depression has destroyed
your life and you lost your girl
i'm telling you that enemy the enemy in
your life isn't real and you're now
sending me 10 emails a week trying to
convince me that your enemy is a real
thing
why are you sticking up for your this
person whatever it is this idea of
destroying you and you're putting your
energy into defending it you should be
on my team whose team are you on here do
you want to see her and convince me i'm
never going to believe you i'm never
going to adopt your thinking because
your life is not successful enough for
me to emulate so why don't you try to
adopt my way of thinking stop defending
this and they're defending it because
it's a cure-all excuse me depression or
sadness is a cure-all excuse for men to
use for failure i have failed this is
why they say i don't believe in men's
mental health or the man the man who's
depressed can't compete with the man
who's not depressed this is this quote i
say listen you get to roll out
be fat be out of shape be broke be
unimportant with no girlfriend and
instead of the world thinking you're a
loser you get to say i'm not a loser i'm
depressed it's a shield
and i say that's why you don't want to
lose your shield because now you have
accountability now you have performance
to cop out [ __ ] it off i don't give a
[ __ ] if it's real or not we're not about
that we're talking about success here
get rid of your excuses stop defending
the thing that's ruined your life and
get to [ __ ] work and every time
anyone has ever listened to me in
history ever every single one of them
has transformed their lives and message
me positive messages afterwards every
single [ __ ] time that's why i'm
anti-anti-depressant because that pill
ain't gonna fix you the way becoming the
man you wish you were is gonna fix you
it's it's crazy and then they're gonna
take one little sound bite tate doesn't
care about men's mental health he thinks
depressed people are zorro that it's
some [ __ ] and they're gonna apply it
to me i really do believe and i state
this almost with the degree of
achievement i'm the most misunderstood
man on the planet
i really believe i am it's crazy the
level people there are people out there
who truly believe i am evil
and i'm i'm nothing i'm not i'm nothing
close to it i'm one of the most
compassionate people you can possibly
meet if you enjoyed this video and you
want to watch the entire podcast click
over here and if you want to be
connected with experts influencers such
as kiyosaki tate connolly parliamentary
myself and others download the app
minect where you get a chance to connect
with these folks by the minute you get
to buy the minute or have face times
with them 15 minutes ask them any
questions you may want to have download
the app connect and start connecting
with influencers and experts today
[Music]